welcome to the festival BAM you're not
near o stranger to boosting our Chi no
stranger to Canada festival land is you
own it man you've been doing it for a
long time do you love outdoor festivals
oh yes certainly I mean you know the
main thing for me is I'm relishing in
any opportunity to get up here and play
music you know we've I mean I look back
over my four or five years since kind of
I get something coming to Canada for
like six years now but um but we enjoy
every moment up here and we we really
appreciate our Canadian fanbase and
certainly so but I love the festival
thing too it's fun watching you know
crazy diehard fans that are willing to
camp out and and brave the elements and
the gust and and and everything that the
festival life can throw that you so on
so yeah it's fun summer festivals are a
blast and probably not so different from
the early days of like when wood bands
are just touring in a band and you have
to you know stop to use the restroom at
at you know at the truck stops yeah like
that right it it's a little blood sweat
and tears that goes into being a true
fan to being a festival for the whole
time yeah I mean they it's it's
certainly a commitment in a dedication
and it was funny I was I took off on my
bike ride and I was road biking around
here and a you know I'm kind of riding
by the campgrounds and come on no you
were not doing it yeah but I kind of can
get in nobody's expecting me on a bike
you know you're talking about like a
like a rush cycling cycling not a motor
side like a Tour de France kind of idea
that you got to tell you have to I don't
know if you do Luke you have to or yo
you won't survive the seat ah right
gotcha okay but but you so you're going
you're but get in and well I wouldn't
call them I mean just like shade yeah I
do like a I do like a redneck version of
it I wear like a luck of Cabela's shirt
up and then just the little pants and
nobody nobody will up by the time I ride
by what's funny is the
people oh I mean people are kind of
heckling a little bit and I'm like you
know who you're heckling you idiot but
it was you guys paid to come and see the
guy you're heckling yeah yeah yeah yeah
and this guy one of you I guess you call
them what do you guys call your police
yeah there's the OPP here you know in
Ontario this is the Ontario Provincial
Police this is not the RCMP I got yeah
well yeah I saw the OPP which is
certainly you're down with them I'm down
with them and so yeah I'm riding back
into the festival and this guy's like
stop I'm like you know and I'm like hey
man I'm Luke and he's like oh god let's
get a selfie so I guess I'll do it
I love that man I love I love the build
up to that moment yeah he's gotta like
I'm in it because it happens to me I'm
screwed yeah I mean when you're on your
bike your your your laminate your tool
and laminate flapping and getting kind
of what you want last time is something
like that happened when you were just
driving around it happened have you were
you maybe breaking a state law somewhere
and you got pulled over and you know
actually we were in Cheyenne Wyoming a
couple of a couple of weeks ago and I
was fishing with my boys and I had to
run over and do armed Frontier Days
and my bus driver we had my bus out
there but my bus driver we we just used
the rental car get run over to Cheyenne
it's about two and a half three hour
driving my um so my bus drivers driving
you know a standard vehicle which was
weird enough I mean I've never had him
drive me around in a real and I like a
regular car and I'm in the passenger
seat and we're going you know it's
slowing I'm in the speed limits like 80
miles an hour you know out there and and
we're going along pretty good and we
start getting pulled over and and and
you know we're in a rental car we don't
even know all the insurances proper or
whatever will so he pulled you know we
pull over and he comes to my side of the
video and I'm like oh yes
we're getting out of this I love that
you like it yeah yeah not even my Allah
he's at my superpowers and yes but he he
we let them win it down and he walks up
to the car and he's like when you guys
go it said I'm playing shush I totally I
thought it out there Mike
well I'm performing tonight over it I'll
Cheyenne Frontier Days oh you are yeah
yes hurry
hi man you know I'm Luke Bryan all boos
you know so then we get out of the
ticket so it was not